on va faire l'interview par amour la
bouche rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on ne bouge pas quand le signal
c'est bien je peux bouger maintenant
par amour est ce que vous seriez prêt à
arrêter de jouer de la guitare
c'est par amour pour vous mais pour moi
oui mais par exemple pour
et alors ça lui plaît de proches
attendent et guitariste bien par amo est
ce que vous seriez prêt à cacher le
corps de quelqu'un que je viens de tuer
un problème
rien est ce que vous seriez prêt par
amour arrêter de fumer
aujourd'hui on a il faut aimer là on
peut pas fumer en plus simple et la plus
droit de fumer avant pouvait fumer du
temps lunettes noires ont fumé donc
c'est bien par amour ouais c'est pas un
fossé il est prêt à arrêter le flux
d'armes lourdes par amour est-ce que
vous accepteriez qu'elle est un amant
pas quand on aime les gens dans big soit
heureux mais je suis d'accord moi ça
veut dire qu'ils aient ou non par amour
et scooter est ce que vous seriez prêt à
accepter que j'ai une maîtresse
[Rires]
oui c'est par amour on est prêt à tout
on est prêt à tout quand on a tout par
amour est ce que vous seriez prêt à
vivre avec ma maîtresse et moi tous les
froids
est ce qu'elle est s'il ya une chatte
dans l'histoire
et vous qu'un ça c'était pas dans
l'interview châtre est-ce que par amour
vous accepteriez que votre jules et une
maîtresse
je crois pas mathieu boulay mais pas
alors mais si je dois même légende envie
qu'il soit heureux
mais je fais tout pour qu'il soit
heureux pardon des mêmes jeux c'est tout
pourri ce taux est heureux oui j'ai pas
jusqu'à quatre et vous mimi j'ai
toujours accepté qu'ils aient des femmes
donc
c'est aussi à la mettra ça fait beaucoup
génial parce que spécialiste des hommes
barbus à rien mais c'est bien comme ça
vous n'avez pas tout le temps sur leur
look ce n'est pas tout sur le dos c'est
mieux c'est compliqué
par amo est ce que vous seriez prête à
vivre à trois avec le mec est l'âme et
n'ont jamais et vous non plus à n'ont
rien à faire avec ces gonzesses
retrouver sans guitare
thomas
si votre maîtresse moi si j'étais votre
amant mais peu importe est ce que vous
seriez prêt à aller tous les samedis
dans un club échangiste
bah ouais si je peux boire un coup au
temps qu'il
votre femme vous a si ma femme me
demandais à givet tout de suite
demandez moi c'est pas une idée à moi
c'est une des cantines est ce que vous
seriez prêt alors je vais dire moi
puisque apparemment est quelque chose
qui se crée entre même ce soir par amour
est ce que vous seriez prêt de lire mon
esclave sexuelle
votre esclave sexuelle ferai tout ce que
je vous demande de la section il fait
tout cela rend ma fille aussi dans le
grand bain non elle n'est pas très
branché sexe mais non et vous par
exemple votre votre jules vous dis voilà
si tu m'aimes tu deviens mon esclave
sexuelle
c'est votre programme c'est l'esclavagé
sexuel
nationale
consulté pas conseil national c'est pas
ça prend une semaine de négociations
courant et on n'y arrivera jamais par
amour ou est-ce que vous prendriez du
viagra
oui il y en a dans les bois sont ici
paris
on est remonté mois ci en plus j'en
prends il va t'il il va mourir
par amour est ce que vous seriez prêt à
vous refaire faire le sexe
comme je joue de la guitare avec mon
sexe série 4 à 6 ans
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux